Indonesia is an incredible country with
17,000 islands 800 languages and
dialects and more than 300 ethnic groups
after centuries of oppression it is
looking for a common future and a
national identity
the idea of a single national language
only came to the fore in the 1920s and
with it emerged modern Indonesian
literature
Linda Christine T writes about the
traumas of the past
okay Bruce Meany explores the tensions
within society
Azari are you writes of things that
can't be said writing as therapy as a
weapon
in Tunisia lies between the Indian and
Pacific Oceans the capital Jakarta is on
the island of Java 30 million people
live in and around Jakarta the city is
booming the country is rich in natural
resources but for a long time its riches
were exploited by colonial powers
Indonesia only gained independence from
the Netherlands after the Second World
War
when I was a child I was so happy
because I live in Indonesia and this
country is very rich and this country
has a lot of languages we have a lot
cultural and we have a large ethnic
sphere and of course at the same time I
worry when I'm thinking about how the
government can mimic this country how
the government can bring prosperity to
the people how the government can bring
justice to the people or everything
because too deep and big country has a
lot of happy stories and a lot of sad
stories too
the writer and journalists Linda Crist
auntie is all too familiar with
Indonesia's sad stories every Thursday
she comes here to the presidential
palace to attend a demonstration of
political activists and critics of the
former Suharto regime may I read a poem
about the people who were seized and
disappeared about our friends who are
kidnapped it's a poem I wrote myself
words against silence Linda wants to
know what happened to friends and
comrades who were abducted during the
military dictatorship the demonstrators
chant we will not be silenced they call
on the president Joko Widodo to bring
the perpetrators to justice
so to hurry heat ammonia dairy to roll
up this weapon jeribai sorry on coupon
pick Iran the acoustic us vinegar
acoustic on Monroe go t cell or Garcia
papania particular content Abeba song
banjaara illiberal apiece apiece bent
opium in Europe I'll appear in Tommy
Hunter sisa blooms Apollonia bebés poppy
cherry Totten bangkalan young Fergie Dan
Peterson valley akan menjadi charity
empress virus can agora peony rose
mignon
the flame of freedom in stone the huge
national monument in the heart of the
capital commemorates the struggle for
independence after three and a half
centuries of foreign rule its
construction started in 1961 under the
direction of the Republic's first
president Sukarno he sought to unite the
nation through nationalism and communism
in 1965 there was a coup eventually
Suharto seized power and remained
president from 1967 until May 1998 he
was ruthless and crushing opponents
in the late 1990s Linda helped organized
the student protests that ultimately led
to the ousting of Suharto she went
underground and wrote anti-regime
articles under a pseudonym I don't know
what happened to us because we are very
young at the time all of us were 20s and
we decided to sacrifice our life to the
people and we know we knew about the
risks maybe the government will arrest
us
maybe they will send us to the jail
maybe they will kill us maybe they will
make us disappear maybe they will send
the military intelligence kidnap us and
all of us we know about it we know about
it at the time but we took the risk
because if nobody dares to do that the
country are the peoples were still the
same no futures for the young generation
under the dictatorship leftist writers
were banned though their works are now
available the ban was never officially
lifted a conspiracy of silence prevails
to this day in Indonesia
despite the restoration of democracy
nobody dares to bring the culprits to
justice it is because of military they
were involved in all of violence pieces
in Indonesia Indonesia was built upon
maybe more than one millions right
people yes and and I think it's almost
impossible to military military to say
oh we will tell you the truth we kidnap
your son we can name your daughter maybe
we kidnap your husband and now we want
to say forgive us it's impossible
it's will never never happen in her
prize-winning literary texts essays and
reports Linda writes about violence and
terror from Sumatra to Timor
Indonesia suffers from enduring tensions
between the interests of the central
government based in the capital on Java
and those of the other islands there is
little that keeps the regions and
islands together an official national
language bahasa indonesia was only
introduced in 1945 after the declaration
of independence i had multiple multi
identity i was born in Long Island
people call me maybe
because I live in this country people
call me Indonesia they call me Muslim
indonesian muslim and when I attend
brighter conference they call me
Indonesian writer identities it's not
something like wood or stones it's like
liquid yes
the majority of Indonesians are Muslim
Indonesia has the largest Muslim
population of any country and it boasts
the largest mosque in Southeast Asia the
eesti cloud or independence mosque in
Jakarta with room for 120,000
worshippers
Linda considers herself a critical
Muslim she's worried that the
traditionally moderate Islam of
Indonesia could be subverted by more
extreme currents she was brought up to
respect others whatever their beliefs
little by little I realize you cannot
understand religion if you only read al
Quran because you have to know more
about politics and you have to know more
about the conflicts between people and
why they fight each others in the name
of God
it was Arab traders who brought Islam to
the region until then hinduism had
prevailed Western colonialists brought
Christianity but it did not really catch
on
many ethnic Chinese here practice
Buddhism or Taoism these days less than
2% of the population call themselves
Hindus in the northwest corner of the
country on the island of Sumatra about
1,800 kilometers from the capital is the
semi-autonomous province of Aceh
there are almost no traces now of the
tsunami that devastated the west coast
of our Chi on December 26 2004 amazingly
this mosque remained standing that
tsunami killed 170,000 people in akshay
province alone for the writer
Azari Ayub the disaster changed
everything
I was born in Banda Aceh I spent my
childhood here before tsunami I live
with my family I have one little sister
and one little brother with the tsunami
all of them disappear
it is still hard for him to talk about
it especially here at the beach where
people relax and swim just as they did
before the huge wave struck his sadness
finds expression in verse but he does
not like to read his poems out loud
himself
Ibuki Abba van dyck Nam
satella Bala akopplin in in militia
Korean Dan Campbell
- Kyra gunam December two momenta burro
tapi aku tamuka korean desana juga Erica
till young Tarawa
support Acharya campaign copernica Sudha
Chiara Gruber
when Jerry loud yeah Mariah
he and his family lived just a couple of
kilometres from the shore vegetation has
filled the plot where his home once
stood
the entire village was washed away
before tsunami we have 700 people but
after we remind 100 people 8
organizations from a hundred countries
came to a chi a region that had been cut
off from the outside world for decades
because of the war between separatist
insurgents and the military after
tsunami many project the contractor in
IJ and bill many host in the tsunami
area half a million people were made
homeless here most now have a roof over
their heads but in their hearts they're
still suffering
look like I am stranger here because so
many newcomer after tsunami in my police
the village where a sari grew up has
been rebuilt new houses and new
residents for sorry the place is still
full of memories the first books his
father gave him the first stories he was
told as a small child my mother is like
a story like like a storyteller sometime
in night or in the afternoon she telling
everything what she know sometime about
the fairy tale sometime about the gossip
and when I am writing something I stolen
the story by mum by my mother as re now
lives on the outskirts of the regional
capital Banda a shave
when that tsunami hit he was far away on
Java
it was days before he heard that his
family had been killed the pictures on
the walls of his home are all of his
wife's family she doesn't have a single
photo of his own parents sister or
brother he says he's frightened he might
forget what they looked like
after that tsunami tens of thousands of
people were buried in mass graves many
had not been identified there's now a
tsunami Museum in Banda Aceh
the names of 5000 of those who perished
are inscribed here
there are dioramas of the event itself
and of the aftermath to help visitors
understand what happened
right beside the museum is a Dutch
military cemetery where more than 2,000
soldiers of the colonial power are
buried the Netherlands and the Sultanate
of Aceh were at war for three decades
until Akshay capitulated in 1903 a
Chinese defined themself as the fighter
the historic Kansas is very high we are
surrounded by the history we talked
about about previous time and we don't
care about what happened in the future
Archie is one of the poorest regions in
Indonesia the war that began in the
1970s between a separatist insurgency
and government forces crippled the
economy for decades many people of
azari's age grew up without their
fathers they were away fighting in the
underground many were captured tortured
and murdered violence was everywhere
even in the most remote villages and it
is very present in azari's short stories
this is the arch a human rights museum
it's based on what used to be a private
home sorry is the director the founder
Raisa yttria who's studying at Harvard
is back for a visit where have you been
oh you've gained weight yes but it's not
from bribe money after the tsunami as
re-shared this house with other artists
and writers who had lost their families
their small community developed into an
art center and a human rights Museum the
tsunami prompted renewed efforts to
resolve the conflict in Aceh a peace
deal was signed in 2005 to ensure the
conflict is not forgotten the museum
collects documents on killings massacres
arson attacks abuses the old and the new
rulers do not want to address anger and
resentment towards the government remain
deep
we know about Indonesia only one face
face injustice face abuse of human
rights and face raping of our woman so
we have problem with Indonesia
at midday on Friday the moussine calls
the faithful to prayer it is not an
invitation but in order Archie is the
only province of Indonesia where Islamic
sharia law is in force it was introduced
in 2001 a questionable gift from the
central government when the sari hollow
applied everything is chain the
authority evaluate you every day you
must go to moss
you must have the standard about what
you are really if you go to somewhere
with you friend or girl you'll be
arrested for atenas the reduce is very
personal right
but the sorry aloo one the city's become
a public the big brother
we're what a standard sorry is a
practicing Muslim but he rejects the
idea of being forced to pray if he
doesn't go to the mosque for prayers he
can't be out on the street so he stays
home he says the government introduced
Sharia as an instrument of control I
don't agree with the sorry hello because
it is politic he is not a Chinese
willing it is the Jakarta willing
Jakarta won't reduce the movement of
independent in a chair like a referendum
and when the goose door roll in
Indonesia
she gives each a sari hollow and you
know we are a Chinese don't reject
something about the Islam as re deals
with the violent past not as a
journalist but as a writer
you can read everything with you
imagination you said it for yourself but
if you are journalist you depend of your
boss or you newspaper but you know
newspaper in Aceh in the CP war is very
bad and all of the journalists in
Indonesia at the time above of the
military who I can believe about the
journalist it is three thousand six
hundred and fifty kilometers from Akshay
to Bali and they are worlds apart
many Westerners consider Bali a tropical
paradise in the early 20th century
European artists cultivated their
utopian fantasy that it was a perfect
place where humans and nature were at
one in perfect harmony Bali is known as
the island of the gods it has a thousand
Hindu temples the magic of the place is
an inspiration for the writer Icarus
Nene Jerry Jerry
Akuma now Varna trauma can purujit
incremental romania wahi another
condiment Asano mantra Santana gherkin
in Paris Tonya unitary Sharon anchor
Akuma mukhin one young line Jerry
Kellerman a Korean - so kandi - woman :
Akuma in can Rasta Vanara common person
young Cooper Tintin comparable Astana
Michelle my DRP vamoosed are booming
with klappa
Oh Clara's meanie has lived on Bali for
25 years she was born in Jakarta to a
Hindu Brahmin family Bali is incredible
I've worked here as a journalist since
1990 it's been a revelation a lot has
changed on the island I like to write
about that not scholarly texts of
anthropology or sociology but works of
fiction novels I won't read us to be
entirely immersed in Balinese society as
if they were part of it
the religious ceremonies and rituals of
the Hindu population are captivating
spectacle
but they embody a hierarchical caste
system with strict rules and tough
sanctions against anyone who breaks them
especially women
from one companion if a woman from a
higher caste marries a man who is not
from barley or belongs to a lower caste
she may no longer visit her family she's
discriminated against I'm gonna be done
there used to be a ceremony called Patti
wangi to expel a woman from her caste
and her family if she married beneath
her but it has been banned
there's no Patti wonky anymore but
discrimination still exists as I
described in my books women are
oppressed not by means of domestic
violence but through psychological
violence
her novel earth dance is about four
generations of women in one family and
the struggle for self-determination in a
complex and rigid caste system
one things have changed nowadays
Balinese women dare to get divorced
they're not afraid to break out of the
world of marriage they have the
self-confidence to live alone because
they're financially independent they
used to remain in bad marriages even
when they were treated badly but now
they take their fate into their own
hands and decide what to do with their
lives their bodies their thoughts their
children their social status they're not
afraid to make their own decisions so
see America strategy otaku 9 billion
Billy honey Armenia the 21st century has
indeed reached Bali
tourism is the most important industry
on the island and it has been a motor
for economic development and for social
change
three million holidaymakers visit Bali
each year the impact of mass tourism on
the environment and on the people of
Bali is considerable paradise is at risk
more and more land is being sold to
investors
there are even plans to build artificial
islands off the coast that would do more
than just disrupt the ecosystem that be
of Binaca the Balinese the earth
mountains and ocean have very specific
meanings imagine the sea becomes earth
that's totally incompatible with the
Hindu view of the world it would be a
great disrespect to the people of bali
bali tourism does have positive aspects
as well it helps the young to establish
contact with the outside world they get
to know people from around the globe and
make new friends and turn
so I think up from now when the up gun I
didn't set out to become a writer I come
from a troubled family my mother left me
when I was six I felt very lonely in
this world I wrote a lot in my diary
then on my birthday I would burn my
Diaries that was my birthday present to
myself during my childhood yeah for me
writing was therapy when I was four I
had polio before that I was a healthy
girl then suddenly I got ill and
couldn't go to ballet anymore I was just
a child but I felt my life was over
mysticum a second a tomato
so-called uh guard up okay is visiting
her friend choke Abby
he is a fashion designer who studied in
London his clothes are in great demand
among the upper-class ladies of the
Balinese capital Denpasar
anymore huh this is Balinese brocade the
dress was inspired by the sea goddess
kangan grotto
in Bali clothing is often closely linked
to religious rituals Chuck Abbey has an
ability to reinterpret traditional
garments such as the caballo blouse
dress combination that's worn at
ceremonies to make something modern you
can wear it to parties oka is a fashion
editor at the local newspaper the Bali
post her enthusiastic reviews
kick-started choked Abbey's career its
androgynous yes it's masculine but the
embroidery makes it feminine and that's
the idea yes it's about black and white
and two shades of grey light and dark
the colors represent day and night dawn
and dusk it's holy material that unites
good and bad sadness and joy Chuck
Abbey's jewelry is also modeled on
ritual objects
to talk you okay here on Bali feminine
beauty is celebrated in Aceh
under Sharia law it is often hidden from
view they are indeed worlds apart
ouka likes to visit the market in
Denpasar
she is not only a writer and journalist
but also a wife and mother and a great
cook
she and her family live in a quiet
neighborhood
her son Pasha Renison helps her make
supper
Oh cos husband is a poet translator and
art curator
they met at a poetry festival theirs is
not a conventional pairing oka is a
Hindu Brahmin her husband a Muslim it's
difficult to make a living as a writer
in Indonesia the market is not large and
few works are translated into other
languages I've never regretted being a
writer it's therapeutic for me and for
my readers remember Telugu say
from Bali it's now back to the capital
Jakarta on the island of Java
some of the biggest demonstrations
during the revolution of 1998 took place
at Trisakti university they contributed
to the downfall of the dictatorship and
the emergence of democracy
today's students living in a free
society our debt of gratitude to those
of linda trest aunties generation who
risked their lives to fight tyranny
Linda Crist auntie now writes for the
fashion and lifestyle magazine dare we
this is magazine for women in the middle
class and in high class for me it's
important to let them know about the
problem in the society and about how we
solve environmental issue problems
because women from this class they have
a lot of money and they have power maybe
they can contribute to change the
society
her activism and political work have
involved sacrifices I need a lot of
freedom because I'm a political person
in my writings
if the Indonesian army or whatever army
special force kidnapped me if they kill
me I will not be sad because I don't
have children I don't have husband I
don't have anything and if I have a
family maybe I worry a lot about my life
she may not have a family of her own
but she has close friends comrades from
their time in the resistance in the
1990s back then nazar patria was seized
by the military when the friends meet
they often talk about the past today
they talk about the father of another
friend who was abducted until his death
the father would make coffee every day
for his absent son he was already in a
wheelchair he was very sad that his
grandchildren didn't have a father he
just could not accept the fact that his
son was never going to come home again
yeah
today Indonesia is a democracy with a
fast-growing economy but it still has
plenty of social and political problems
so Linda Chris Don T's work is far from
finished I have to keep going I have to
do what I team I have to do if you want
to change something in the society you
have to be brief to the deaths maybe you
are not alone maybe in the world there
are some people like you maybe they live
in the world situations more than me and
because of that I never feel alone
for Linda Crist auntie it is hard to
shake off a sense of mistrust and
anxiety that might never change
but this too is part of her complex
identity she enjoys karaoke she sings
with friends from her student days their
shared past is an enduring bond
they sing in bahasa indonesia the
national language of this huge and
fractured country the language of
Indonesia's courageous writers who will
not be silenced